Having one of those, like,
what goes around comes around moments, and I am living for it.
Go watch her video because it's really funny.
But also I just wanted to add on, like,
a little bit of, like,
sociological context to what's happening.
So men forever have benefited from the system that men had set up,
which we know is the patriarchy.
And if you don't believe that the patriarchy is, like,
a real thing, you can scroll on by.
This video is not for you.
But those of us who have been trying to educate ourselves on feminist
principles and feminism,
as in general,
recognize that patriarchy hurts men, too.
And this taps into things like ageism,
into body dysmorphia and, like, imagery.
I actually saw a really great live yesterday from my sister,
who's actually a cosplayer,
and she was talking about men's mental health
and body image within the cosplay community.
And I myself am not in the cosplay community,
but I can absolutely be enthralled by a conversation about body image,
because all of that is an offshoot of, like,
patriarchal and white supremacist beauty standards,
which for women, are extremely strict.
But there is also a male beauty standard as far as, like,
physique, that has been created by men.
And you can say all day long that, like,
women have this idea of a male beauty standard.
Absolutely. But there is a really interesting study that I saw
where men and women were Shown hyper feminine or hyper masculine
photos of like,
the same image.
And men always were most attracted to the hyper feminine
version of a woman,
whereas women were not necessarily
always attracted to the hyper masculine version of men
because they saw it as, like,
threatening and aggressive.
They liked, like, a pull back,
like, not fully all the way hyper masculine.
And it kind of goes the same way with, like, attitude.
That alpha male,
hyper masculine,
toxic red pill bullshit is no longer flying for women and men.
Not all men. Cause people get mad when I, like,
lump everyone all in together.
Not all men, but the men who have completely bought into
and ascribed to this patriarchal standard of what manhood is
are the ones being hurt the most.
And the only way it's ever gonna change is if men get on board
and realize how much patriarchy hurts them too.
Leaves them unable to talk about their feelings,
unable to have true intimate relationships
because they can't fully be intimate and vulnerable emotionally
with either their friends or their partner,
and judge people based on their physical appearance,
including themselves.
So until the men get on board with dismantling the patriarchy,
they, they indeed are having a fuck around and find out moment.
And I don't know how I feel about that, because, like,
the petty in me wants to be happy about it,
but the, like, compassionate, empathetic,
like a lover of good Men,
lover of my husband,
lover of my sons,
wants better for them.
So I just hope that this leads to a movement of men joining feminism.
Or maybe we need to rebrand it as just, like,
literally just gender Equality,
because the word feminism scares off a lot of people,
which is annoying.
But maybe then we need the men to join the movement,
because this isn't good for y'all either.